[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is a question i get so often so when
using these phones or tablets or
computers or whatever uh you got to have
a case for it right you got to have some
sort of protection that you need to
worry about uh so this is me answering
that question this is why i don't use
cases so more and more especially
recently these new flagship phones that
are coming out are focused more and more
on their design specs matter less and
less so we're seeing these new phones
come out and no matter what the specs
are quad-core this ram speed that
doesn't really matter basically every
phone at the top of every manufacturer's
lineup performs great so the way to pick
which phone you buy is number one the
software features and number two the
design and the hardware and the feel on
the hand so that's why these
manufacturers have spent hundreds and
hundreds of hours of research and
development creating these meticulously
precise designs where every curve every
edge has a reason the button placement
the build materials the shape the size
everything is considered and everything
has a purpose they make the phone
thinner they make the phone lighter they
push the limits of physics to fit as big
a battery or as many camera lenses or as
big as speakers as possible into this
beautifully designed phone so when you
finally decide which six or seven
hundred dollar phone you wanna buy
you'll really appreciate these little
details these fine things that they've
considered and you'll hopefully really
appreciate the design but then a case
manufacturer comes along and no offense
to any case manufacturers but they spend
maybe a week
to study the dimensions of this new
phone and come up with a piece of rubber
or plastic to put over the top of your
phone to protect it and so you put this
piece of rubber on your phone and then
the beauty is gone like the meticulous
edges the sharp details the design all
the curves everything that they were
trying to impress you with and the way
it feels in the hand is gone the
thinness that they brag about on every
new flagship phone when you put that
piece of rubber on top is now gone but
you want to protect the phone what if
you drop it you got to have some sort of
protection on the phone for that right
well turns out the drop tests where they
actually have a case on the phone are
actually at least a little bit useful
because they've shown that basically no
case with a few exceptions basically no
case actually prevents your phone from
getting damaged when you drop it from
any significant height when you drop
your phone on the screen especially is
going to get damaged unless it's an
otterbox defender so really the
protection a case offers is against
direct impact between your phone and
whatever surface you drop your phone on
so if you drop a metal phone on concrete
you prevent that metal from getting
scratched which is great but so do skins
there's skins that you can apply just
like a screen protector it's just on the
back of your phone uh really are thick
enough at this point to actually protect
your phone the same amount as a thin
rubber case would
against the drop from maybe pocket
height
they also tend to improve the feel on
the hand worst case scenario you have
the htc one m8 this is a tall large
rounded metal phone uh and if you want
to touch the top of the phone and grab
that power button with one hand you
inevitably have to do a little shimmy
with your hand and with those smooth
rounded edges that's just asking to drop
your phone eventually so i added a
carbon fiber textured skin to the back
of my phone problem solved and that's
kept the phone's thinness it hasn't
changed the shape of the phone the only
thing that's really changed is the way
it feels in the hand because you now
have that texture so i guess the only
thing you have to worry about is the
actual visual looks of the phone and
that's not really a problem anymore
because a lot of these skin
manufacturers have tons of different
colors and looks and build materials and
all sorts of things for the most popular
phones out there i also have a skin on
my laptop it's a decal from
decalgirl.com don't judge for the
13-inch retina macbook pro obviously
that's a device you don't really drop
that much but it does protect it when i
pull it in and out of my bag from any
scratching with a zipper or something
and at the end of the day if i want to
sell the laptop or get rid of it i can
just take the skin off and it leaves a
metal underneath perfectly new so bottom
line i really don't use cases on my
laptop or tablet or phone and that's
because i actually care about the design
of it and if you do too it doesn't
really make sense to cover that up with
the piece of rubber or plastic so i i'm
going to encourage the the skin makers
out there the d brands the decal girls
the slick wraps all those guys to keep
making more awesome skins for us to
customize our phones the way they look
and the way they feel in the hand
and if i actually need to protect my
phone i'll put it back in my pocket or
get an otterbox defender i guess without
any further ado i'll go ahead and sign
off let me know what you guys are are
you a case person are you a skin person
or do you carry your phone naked because
i know lots of people like it naked